Jonathan hope runs a successful Food
business in West London and he's also
one of the three million odd britons who
invest in cryptocurrency
so you've got in Badger being me so I'll
show you and while his beans are
fermenting nicely his crypto has been
doing less well a big crash yesterday
ended a long slide wiping nearly a
trillion dollars off cryptocurrencies
Jonathan has lost around ten thousand
pounds
yeah yeah it's it's painful but you have
to step back and look at it with
perspective I'm making bets on a
five-year time frame like the only way
you can look at that is with gratitude
like I'm so grateful to be in the
position that I'm in and nobody should
ever invest money because they can't
afford to lose cryptocurrencies famous
ones like Bitcoin ethereum Solana and
Dogecoin are created by solving
complicated mathematical problems
allowing them to be added to a secure
digital Ledger called a blockchain
unique and digital in theory
cryptocurrencies are secure and stable
but so far they've turned out to be
anything but speculation has made them
highly volatile look at the recent ups
and downs in the price of Bitcoin and
that's led to an increase in the
popularity of stable coins crypto
currencies whose value is pegged to real
ones like the dollar and they use
largely as a way of safely banking
profits only yesterday so stable coins
slipped their financial Moorings leading
to onecoin Terra Luna becoming
effectively worthless overnight
some investors were more exposed than
others YouTuber and rapper KSI was
holding 157 000 Luna tweeting today that
he'd lost nearly 2.8 million dollars in
the crash
so is this just another dip on the
crypto roller coaster or are the wheels
coming off everything's an experiment
some work some don't the ones that don't
the learnings play out in public it's
pretty much a feature not a bug of
crypto
um it's just that we we have to go
through these teething pains now
at some point Regulators will have to
step into the wild west of digital
currency but will it end the volatility
I don't think regulation would have
changed the situation that we are in now
because although it would protect
against fraud which is a fantastic thing
and it potentially would give people
more knowledge about the risks I I don't
think anybody thought that
cryptocurrency was not risky with the
real economy in a global slowdown the
crypto crash May deter investors for a
while but few doubt that the future of
money is digital just getting there will
be a very bumpy ride
Tom Clark Sky News